hey everyone
welcome to this video where we look into
the rampant spyware program that is the
pegasus service
be sure to subscribe to simplylearn for
more amazing content like this and hit
the bell icon for notifications about
newly updated videos
we also have a quiz in this video so
stay tuned till the end
before we learn about the pegasus
platform let us understand what spyware
is and it's working spyware is a
category of malware that can gather
information regarding a user or a device
straight from the host machine it is
mostly spread by malicious links via
email or chat applications when a link
with the malware is received clicking on
this link will activate the spyware
which allows the hacker to spy on all
our user information with some spyware
systems even clicking on the link isn't
necessary to trigger the malicious
payload
this can ultimately cause security
complications and further loss of
privacy
one such spyware system that is making
the rounds in the tech industry today is
pegasus the pegasus is a spyware system
developed by an israeli company known as
the nso group it runs on mainly mobile
devices spanning across the major
operating systems like the apple's ios
and iphone and the standard android
versions this is not a newly developed
platform since pegasus has existed since
as early as 2016.
a highly intricate spyware program that
can track user location
read text messages scan through mobile
files access device camera and
microphone to record voice and video
pegasus has all the tools necessary to
enforce surveillance for any client that
wishes to buy its services initially the
nso group had designed the software to
be used against terrorist factions of
the world
with more and more encrypted
communication channels coming to the
forefront pegasus was designed to
maintain control over the data
transmission that can be a threat to
national security
unfortunately the people who bought the
software had complete control over who
how and up to what level they can put
surveillance limits on
eventually the primary clients became
sovereign nations spying on public
information that is supposed to stay
private became really easy with the
service
multiple devices can be effect with the
same spyware system to create a network
information this network keeps feeding
data to the host to understand how a
network can be created let's know how a
mobile device can be affected by pegasus
we all communicate with friends and
family over instant messaging
applications and email in some instances
if you check your inbox on a regular
basis you must have noticed that we
receive some spam emails that the mail
providers like gmail and yahoo can just
filter into the spam folder some of
these messages bypass this filter and
make their way into a person's inbox
they look like generic emails which are
supposed to be safe the pegasus spyware
targets such occurrences bypassing
malicious messages and links which
install the necessary spy software on
the user's mobile device be it android
or an iphone
this isn't unique to the email ecosystem
since it's equally likely to be targeted
by sms stacks whatsapp instagram or even
the most secure messaging apps like
signal and three more
once the malicious links are clicked a
spyware package is downloaded and
installed on the device
after the spyware is successfully
installed the perpetrator who sent the
payload to the victim can monitor
everything the user does
pegasus can collect private emails
passwords images videos and every other
piece of information that passes through
the device network all this data is
transmitted back to the central server
where the primary spying organization
can monitor the activities at a granular
level this is not even surface level
since complex spyware software like
pegasus can access the roots files on
our mobiles
these root files hold information that
is crucial to the working of the android
and ios operating systems
leaking such private information is a
massive blow to the security and the
privacy of an individual
the information that may seem trivial
like the name of your wi-fi connection
or the last time you ordered an item
from amazon are indeed all valuable
information this exploitation is
primarily possible due to the zero-day
vulnerabilities known as bugs in the
software development process
the zero-day bugs are the ones that have
just been discovered by some independent
security company or researcher
once they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either google
for android or apple for ios is the
right thing to do
however many such critical bugs make
their way onto the dark web where
hackers can use them to create exploits
these exploits are then sent to innocent
users with a link or a message like we
had discussed before
pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with all the security patches
installed but some bugs are not reported
to the developers or just cannot be
fixed without breaking some core
functionality
these become the gateway for spyware to
enter into the system
you can never be 100 safe but you sure
can give it all in protecting yourself
the one thing where pegasus stands out
is a zero click action feature usually
in spam emails the malicious code is
activated when the user clicks the
malware link a user doesn't need to
click the link in the new version of the
pegasus and a few other spyware programs
once the message arrives in the inbox of
whatsapp gmail or any other chat
applications the spyware gets activated
and everything can be recorded and sent
back to the central server the primary
issue with being affected by spyware as
a victim is detection
unlike cryptominers and trojans spying
services usually do not demand many
system resources which makes them tough
to detect after they have been activated
since many devices slow down after a
couple of years
any kind of performance set due to such
spyware is often attributed to poor
software longevity by the users they do
not check meticulously for any other
causes that is causing the slowdown
when left unchecked these devices can
capture voice and video from the mobile
sensors while keeping the owner in the
dark let's take a moment to check if you
are well aware of the causes of such
attacks
how do users fall prey to such spyware
programs a by installing untested
software b by clicking on the third
party links from email and messages
c by not keeping the apps and phones
updated or d all of the above let us
know your answers in the comment section
below and we will revit the correct
answer next week but what about the
unaffected devices the vulnerable ones
while we cannot be certain of our
security there are a few things we can
do to boost our device
be it against pegasus or the next big
spyware on the market
let's say we are safe now and we have
the time to take the necessary steps to
prevent a spyware attack
what are the things we can go for
a primary goal must always be to keep
our apps and the operating system
updated the latest security patches the
vulnerabilities that the exploits target
are often discovered by developers from
google and apple which send the security
patches quickly
this can be done for individual apps as
well so keeping them updated is of
utmost importance
while the most secure devices have
fallen prey to pegasus as well a
security patch from developers may help
in minimizing the damage at a later
stage or maybe negate the entire spyware
platform altogether
another big factor is the spread of
malware is the trend of side loading
android applications using dot apk files
downloading such apps from a third party
website have no security checks involved
and are mostly responsible for adware
and spyware invasions on user devices
avoiding the side loading of apps would
be a major step in protecting yourself
we often receive spam emails or text
from people we may not know on social
medias
they are accompanied with links that
allow malware to creep into our device
we should try to follow the trusted
websites and not click on any links that
redirect us to unknown domains
spyware is a controversial segment in
governance
while the ramifications are pretty
extreme in theory it severely impacts
user privacy against authoritarian
regimes
sufficient resources and a contingent
plan can alter the false wave of
democracy altogether
even if our daily life is rather
simplistic we must understand that
privacy is not about what we have to
hide
instead it portrays the things we have
to protect it stands for everything we
have to share with the outside world
both rhetorically and literally hope you
enjoyed the video on prigus's spyware if
you have any questions regarding the
topic drop your queries in the comments
and we will get back to you as soon as
possible thank you for watching and stay
tuned for new videos on simpler
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here